c'est une histoire qui débute par une
vidéo de lucas enfant atteint d'une
leucémie qui demande le maillot de son
club préféré après avoir envoyé un
maillot bourg peronnas publie une vidéo
du petit lucas arborant la tunique
thomas félix responsable communication
du club est alors contacté par des
homologues eux aussi avaient été
démarché par la famille mais avec des
noms de famille différents et des
maladies différentes twitter s'emballe
et s'indignent les clubs demandent
réparation j'avais appelé le père qu pas
de réponse au départ l'aj auxerre aussi
a demandé à récupérer le maillot comme
nous l'a fait aussi sinon on pourrait
engager des poursuites judiciaires au
total une dizaine de clubs de ligue 2 et
de national aurait été abusé par le père
et la mère de cet enfant
alors scandale allez-y maxime guinée
c'est honteux c'est scandaleux on est
content quand on y va pour quoi
récupérer un simple maillot de football
faire placer son enfant pour malades non
il est malade alors on n'avait pas la
réponse dans quoi je n'ai pas la réponse
oui ce qui est gênant c'est qu'ils
avancent plusieurs maladies qui dit à
chaque fois qu'il est originaire d'une
ville différente aux indigènes on sait
qu'à partir de maintenant tous les clubs
vont se méfier des enfants l'histoire
est authentique boukessassa un premier
problème et tu vois la la la la la
confiance et les rompus c'est honteux de
faire ça ils manipulent leurs propres
enfants et il leur a pris puisqu'il est
visiblement évidemment mineurs il lui
apprennent en fait que mentir et
s'inventer une fausses ou vraies
maladies en tout cas plusieurs maladies
c'est un moyen d'obtenir des choses des
gens je trouve ça honteux ils doivent au
moins rendre les maillots c'est ce que
demandent les clubs voire être condamné
c'est très grave si l'on fait le malade
pas malade c'est une arnaque c'est une
usurpation d'identité lierse
cherche-t-on étonnant c'est pas le bon
terme usap n'y a pas eu
d'escroquerie a évidemment je suis
totalement d'accord assez scandaleux
c'est condamnable et tout mais je me
demande où la question je me pose moi en
tant que maman en tant que parent
jusqu'où les gens sont ils prêts à aller
si effectivement ils sont dans la
tourmente si ce que dit d'ailleurs
l'article sont dans la tourmente qu'ils
ont peut-être pas de revenus si l'enfant
est avéré véritablement atteint de
leucémie doit y avoir des lourdeurs de 2
serait médicaux et où peut-être qu'ils
sont tellement pris à la gorge qui l'ont
trouvé une sorte de façon à plus d'1
peut avoir enfin petit pie xii face à la
gagner à la différence de ceux qui
lancent des cagnottes quand il ya un
problème pour une opération
c'est bien c'est le demande dd soit pour
ceux qui veulent y aller raconter une
histoire qui n'existe pas ça pour un
maillot de foot et les sportifs
naturellement généreux qui peuvent le
temps de répondre positivement sans que
l'enfant soit malade là en l'occurrence
c'est une escroquerie à d'autres non et
j'espère qu'ils seront surtout condamné
puisque les clubs certains clubs ont
porté absolue mauritanienne oui est ce
que tu dis ma par exemple moi je
pardonnerai plus à ses parents s'ils
sont dans la tourmente et six ans des
enfants malades de voler dans un
supermarché que de faire ça parce que
comme l'a dit guillaume c'est très grave
moi je suis marraine d'une association à
sourire pour camille et je vois ses
parents d'une vraie petite fille malade
qui se battent pour réaliser les rêves
des enfants et tout ça et justement
c'est aussi une confiance quand on
demande à des clubs justement d'aller
voir des joueurs et tout ça et là comme
c'est vraiment c'est ça le mois c'est ce
qui est le pire c'est ça c'est de rompre
cette confiance et il va y avoir
maintenant un doute et ça c'est horrible
pour toutes les familles qui se battent
au quotidien